hey everyone diavolo here and welcome to
my new series in which i'm going to be
going over the entire history of
specific anime and manga characters from
a variety of different series
in this video we are going to be going
over the entire life and history of toji
foshigodo inside of the jiu-jitsu
universe
but before we get into all of that i
just have to inform you all that if you
don't hit that subscribe button and like
the video within the next 10 seconds
gege akotame himself will personally
kill off your favorite character i was
informed by
satellite communications this morning
that he has decided to make this
decision himself
but enough of that let's get into the
entire history of toji fujigodo
so toji was born togi zenin as a member
of the xenon family his childhood is
mostly shrouded in mystery with only a
few mentions throughout the series
so far of his early years so i will do
my best to piece it together for all of
you
sometime during his childhood at a
currently unknown day but most likely
during his birth toji was given a
heavenly restriction that completely
wiped out the curse energy that he
possessed it was said by yuki
later in the series that he was the only
known person to have ever lowered their
curse energy to zero
in the early years toji decided to see
what all this fuss was about to do with
a young sataro gojo and his six-eyes
technique
in which he was astonished to find gojo
was the only person who ever noticed his
presence while standing directly behind
him
while still in the zenon family at an
early age he was often abused and
mistreated
being thrown into rooms filled with
curses as punishment and having to fight
his way out to survive
this abuse from the zenon family
resulted in toji leaving the clan at
probably a similar age to when maki also
decided to leave the xenon family
after leaving the clan toji decided to
take the name sorcerer killer and was
often hired by different groups of
people to
assassinate a variety of targets during
his time as an assassin he meet an
unknown woman who he may have married or
just dated but he ended up having a
child with her thus being the duagonist
of the series
megami foshigoro after the xenon family
found out the news that toji had a child
a meeting was set up between naobito and
toji to discuss selimegami to the
xenonclan in which it was finalized that
once megami's cursed energy manifested
he would be sold to the clan for
some around 100 to 1 billion which
correlates to the 8 to 10 figure number
set in the series
from the point of toji selling megami to
the start of the gojo pasta is still
completely unknown but back in 2006
toji met shueikong who was a member of
the time vessel association there he
decides to accept a job to assassinate
the star placement vessel and then skips
to toji meeting kong again and
informing the group that he had used all
of their money to place a bounty on rico
omani better known as the star plasma
vessel
the reasoning behind this was to wear
down both gojo and ghetto before he
finally made his move with toji creating
a deadline on the bounty it gave the
group the feeling that after the timer
ran out they would relax and not expect
another attack
kong listens to what toji has to say
then decides to leave but not before
asking toji how his son megami was doing
sadly by this point toji had already
completely forgotten about the young
megamie
and was completely focused on money
responding with the question asking shui
kong who is that person
the day comes when riko is to merge with
master tengen and complete the ritual
but toji finally makes his move and
sneak attacks gojo winking him through
the body with a blade
ghido then uses one of his curses to
swallow toji instead of being caught
though toji effortlessly cuts himself
free using one of his many cursed
weapons
gojo then faces off against toji in a
one-on-one fight before they start
fighting gojo tells toji that the bounty
was taken down
thinking that toji was just another
assassin after the money this leads to
the revelation
that toji was the mastermind behind the
entire bounty sheen
and that he only ever used the bounty to
weaken his opponents the fight starts
with toji managing to evade all of
gojo's attacks and maneuver out of
goju's line of sight with gojo being
unable to sense his target due to his
heavenly restriction he clears the
battlefield to gain his sight on toji
back but this backfires instantly with
fushigoto's release of a swarm of
insects to block gojo's view
using his lack of sight toji attacks
from his blind spot
stabbing him through the throat with the
inverted spear of heaven
a weapon designed to be able to nullify
cursed techniques once it makes contact
he then slashes him all over and finally
stabs him with a small knife
leaving him on the ground seemingly dead
bleeding out
after thinking that he has taken care of
gojo he uses the footprints and his
enhanced senses to track down the star
plasma vessel and the others
instantly after arriving and before
ghetto notices anyone was there
togi shoots rico in the head when an
extremely shocked ghetto asks toji how
he is even here
toji says that he has killed gojo and
ghetto instantly begins to engage
toji while fighting toji starts
explaining how he was able to remain
invisible at the college and how he
fights but ghetto doesn't really pay
much attention instead wants to know how
he found him
and rico and what happened to masato
toji replied saying that he took her out
but isn't completely sure
if she died or is still alive giro
manages to take advantage of the fight
momentarily and does his best
to the god toji by trying to
steal the curse that stores toji's
weapons
instead of good of succeeding toji's
uncanny control of his curse took over
and it refused to merge with ghetto toji
defeats each of guido's strongest curses
and slashes him across the chest then
kicks him to the ground and tells him
that their abilities were useless in
stopping someone with no powers
and that he would have died if it wasn't
for all of the curses that he stored
he then remembers his son's name
randomly and why he named amigami
poggi then proceeds to take riko's body
to the time vessel association's base to
be verified after meeting with sonodo
the representative for the association
he heads off with his employer
and then leaves once the association
transfers the money to their account
waiting outside the association base
toji is shocked to find gojo who has
used reversed curse technique to heal
himself
though he was still delirious in a
mnemonic state gojo explains how he
managed to figure out his technique and
that toji almost killing him helped
master his abilities and further get
stronger
toji then takes on gojo thinking that he
is probably delirious with how manic he
was acting
but this time it's different toji is
easily overwhelmed by the reborn gojo
while trying to quickly analyze gojo's
new different abilities to formulate a
counter-attack
he gets completely obliterated by gojo's
ability that he created by combining
gojo's hollow blue and hollow red into a
completely new attack
called hollow purple resulting in a
fatally wounded toji
this attack made toji realize something
his whole mental ideal of
i don't work for free had slipped away
and he had realized that he had changed
wanting admiration for crushing the
pinnacle of the jiu jitsu world
at that point he had already lost not
realising he hadn't put aside such pity
pride he thought he had chosen the path
to be proud of neither myself nor others
as he slowly starts to fade away gojo
asks if toji had anything to say for his
last words
in which toji decides to say nope then
remembering his child megami who will
never know his father
said to his killer in two or three years
my kid will be sold off to the xenon
family
do as you please he then dies this
causes gojo to track down megami
hoping to tell him about his father
flashful to 2018 and the shibuya
incident arc
ogami uses her science technique to
transform her grandson
into toji so that he can gain his
abilities and aid in her battle
after toji defeats eno the personality
suddenly gets taken over by toji
this shocks ogami and toji explains that
copying his body was a huge mistake
because his body is different it's
special
and if his orders were to attack and
kill sorcerers then he would start off
by killing ogami
he attacks her and because ogami's
technique continues after her death and
the fact that her grandson
lacked the curse energy to take control
back meant toji remained active
hungering for fights until his body
become unable to continue or is
destroyed
somehow toji manages to find dagon's
domain and enters through megami's
incomplete domain expansion while megami
and the rest of the group were trying to
leave through it toji then snatches
playful cloud from maki
and gets ready to engage dagon
completely ignoring naobita and focusing
on the curse ahead
toji manages to take out all of degon's
shikigami and beat him to a pulp using
pure physical power
toji then rubs the ends of playful cloud
together to create extremely sharp
points
when daegon tries to escape from toji
naobiro blocks dagon from leaving and
gives toji the chance to pierce dagon
dagon tries to proclaim that it isn't
over but toji doesn't lay up and
continues to stab dagon until he is
exercised
after dagon passes togi turns towards
megami then grabs and drags him to
another location so that they could
fight
megami uses his escape rabbit technique
to try and cover toji
and slow him down but toji easily dashes
past the rabbits and attacks him megami
manages to dodge
and dashes quickly down an alley in
which toji gives chase
after toji attacks and misses he falls
into the trap that megami had created
megami tries to stab toji but toji
easily manages to get away from megami
all of a sudden toji seemed to have
regained his senses from complete
bloodlust
and asks for megami's name in which
migami tells him
miguemi for shigoro toji realizing that
the young man standing before him
as his son is glad to know that he
hasn't taken the name of the zenin
family
he then stabs himself in the head
destroying ogami's grandson
and ending the fight between father and
son so i hope you all enjoyed my video
on the entire life of toji fujigodo
if you guys are new around here and want
to see more content just like this then
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and also leave a like on the video if
you do
enjoy my content as it really helps out
with the algorithm also
if you want to see another entire life
of then make sure to drop a comment down
below with who you'd like to see
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in a bit bye
[Music]